Let’s talk about Donald Trump
and what he might do now that he’s lost the election.
The big American news networks
did the math and
called Biden’s win.
But Trump is contesting
some results in court.
So can Trump still
win in court?
What can he do with
the time
he has left in the
White House?
And what if he
refuses to leave?
No presidential candidate
in the history of
the United States
has ever outright
refused to concede.
Richard Nixon bowed out
even after accusing
John F Kennedy and the Democrats of rigging votes.
Vice President Al Gore accepted the Supreme Court’s
ruling that George W Bush won in Florida.
That was after a
long legal battle
and a recount that
came up with
a razor-thin difference
of 537 votes.
But Trump’s not giving up.
And there are things
he can still do.
In a tight race, a candidate can request a recount.
Georgia has already
agreed to one.
But recounts have only
ever led to totals
that change by a
few dozen votes
sometimes hundreds.
Biden’s lead in
battleground states
is in the tens of thousands.
A candidate can also
file a lawsuit
if they suspect irregularities.
The Trump campaign has challenged electoral processes
in several states over things like Republican observers
not getting close enough to the counting process
ballots - that
are otherwise valid -
being counted after Election Day, and allegations of fraud.
but lawsuits in Michigan, Georgia, Wisconsin
and Arizona have
already failed.
Still - Trump’s lawyer
Rudy Giuliani says
they’re going to
keep going.
The election timetable
means legal battles
can’t go on forever.
In most states recounts and court challenges
have to wrap up by
December 8.
Dec 14 is when electors from each state come together
as the Electoral College
to cast their votes.
The presidential race has been called for Biden
because enough
Democrat electors
are expected to
confirm his victory.
After all that Trump can make all the noise he wants
but it won’t affect who takes the Office of the President.
He doesn’t even have to concede publicly.
That’s just a - usually - respected tradition.
Whatever happens, it’ll all be over - officially -
when Trump’s term ends at noon on January 20, 2021.
That’s when the new president is sworn in.
So what happens if Trump refuses to leave?
But Trump still has 10
weeks left in office.
And a lot can happen
in 10 weeks.
He’ll still be commander-in-chief
and can make important foreign policy decisions.
George Bush Sr
for example
sent troops to Somalia
in his final weeks
and Jimmy Carter ended the Iran hostage crisis.
Trump can also declassify information
and use the power of the presidential pardon
to free people from
prison or stop a trial
if it’s a federal case.
The president had to know he was in trouble
when even Fox News
his favourite TV channel
called his defeat.
Some of Trump’s allies
including the Israeli prime minister
have already
congratulated Biden.
None of that means Trump can’t put up a fight.
It’s his right.
But it’s probably not going to get him very far.